again michael jackson's man in the
mirror
is uh teaching you that it's your
responsibility to just improve yourself
you know if you want to make the world a
better place take a look at yourself and
make the change
this whole concept of again i mean all
of these songs you can listen to them
shallowly or you can just listen to them
and say
oh there's deeper meaning here and i
think there's a certain philosophy
of of song as a way of touching the
psyche
so if you look at regions of the brain
people have lost their language ability
because they have an accident in that
region of the brain can actually
sing because it's exactly the symmetric
region
of the brain and that again teaches you
so much about language evolution
and sort of the the duality of
musicality and you know rhythmic
patterns and
eventually language do you have a sense
of why songs
developed so you're kind of suggesting
that it's possible that
there is something important about our
connection with song and with music on
the level of
the importance of language is it
possible it's not just possible in my
view
language comes after music language
comes after song
no seriously like basically my view of
human cognitive evolution
is rituals if you look at many early
cultures
there's rituals around every stage of
life
there's organized dance performances
around mating and if you look at mate
selection i mean that's an evolutionary
drive right there
so basically if you're not able to
string together a complex dance
as a bird you don't get a mate and that
actually forms
this development for many song
learning birds not every bird knows how
to sing
and not every bird knows how to learn a
complicated song
so basically there's birds that simply
have the same
few tunes that they know how to play and
a lot of that is inherent and
genetically encoded
and others are birds that learn how to
sing
and the you know if you look at a lot of
these exotic birds of paradise and stuff
like that like
the mating rituals they have are
enormously amazing
and i think human mating rituals of you
know ancient tribes
are not very far off from that and in my
view the sequential formation
of these movements is a prelude
to the cognitive capabilities that
ultimately enable language
and it is fascinating to think that
that's uh not just an accidental
precursor to intelligence
yeah it's uh actually selected it's well
sexually selected
and it's a prerequisite yeah it's like
it's required for intelligence
and and even as language has now
developed
i think the artistic expression is
needed
like badly needed by our brain so
it's not just that oh our brain can kind
of you know take a break and go do that
stuff
no i mean you know i don't know if you
remember that scene from
oh gosh we're certain technically moving
new hampshire
uh all all work and no play make jackal
dull boy
boy shining the shining
there's this amazing scene where he's
constantly trying to
to concentrate and what what's coming
out of the typewriter is just gibberish
and i have that image as well when i'm
when i'm working and i'm like
no basically all of these crazy you know
huge number of hobbies that i have
they're not just tolerated by my work
they're required by my work this ability
of sort of stretching your brain in all
these different directions
is connecting your emotional self and
your cognitive self
and that's a prerequisite to being able
to be cognitively
capable at least in my view yeah i
wonder if the world without art and
music
you're just making me realize that
perhaps that world would be
not just devoid of fun things to look at
or listen to but
devoid of all the other stuff all the
bridges and rockets
and science exactly exactly creativity
is not disconnected from art
and you know my kids i mean you know i
could be
doing the full math treatment to them no
they play the piano and they play the
violin and they play sports i mean
this whole you know sort of movement
and going through mazes and playing
tennis
and you know playing soccer and avoiding
obstacles
and all of that that forms your
three-dimensional view of the world
being able to actually move and run and
play in three dimensions
is extremely important for math for you
know stringing together complicated
concepts
it's the same underlying cognitive
machinery
that is used for navigating mazes and
for
navigating theorems and sort of solving
equations so
i can't you know i can't have a
conversation with my students without
you know sort of either using my hand or
opening the white board in zoom and just
constantly drawing
or you know back when we had in-person
meetings just the whiteboard in my
whiteboard yeah that's fascinating to
think about
you